[Music]
seriously man
i'm just being honest i think the bunny
suit is just a little much
excuse me
right rabbit okay my fault
hey four-year-old virgin get over here
let's go uh-huh captain khakis come here
go let's go come on bud
closer there he is blue shirt guy
blue shirt yes hello officer
rabbit nice skin thank you
that's sweet how'd you get it well uh
mostly genetics i think i'm pretty lucky
i have i have naturally dewy skin listen
up neutrogena
you know you can't go around looking
like that the rules are clear and
another thing you can't hack the npc
avatar no sir it screws up the mission
loads
and it makes the game look bad horrible
i got like
five percent of that lose the skin i
lose how much to get rid of my skin take
it off man
just take it off what are you doing what
seriously the whole thing the face the
outfit
everything ditch it if you don't we're
gonna kill you and we're gonna
keep killing you still watch until we do
find out who you are and then we're
gonna
ban you for life no no okay i i want to
comply
i just find the order of those threats
very cute somebody's about to get [ __ ]
free guy only in theaters august 13th
my name is guy sunday should be warm and
sunny just a scattering of drive-bys
and i live in paradise
i've got a best friend this is the
greatest cup of coffee of all time
mondays am i right joe you said it guys
and i work
at the bank
i thought i had everything i needed but
then
i met her everybody down on the ground
everybody accept you please i have a
cold fist there's something inside you
guys i don't want something inside me i
expected you to just follow the rules
but you are so much more than that
put these on okay fine oh my god
what are these trick glasses or
something guy
there is no easy way to say this this
world it's a video game
you're not real please
[Applause]
and the guy responsible for this world
was going to destroy it
you've met god yes he's an absolute
troll trolls exist
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters
i am sitting here with my best friend
trying to help him get through a tough
time
now if that's not real i don't know what
it is i know this world is just a game
for this place these people that's all i
have
so i'm not gonna be the good guy next
guy i'm gonna be the great guy
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity off you go
this whole good guy routine is ruining
the game
terminator it's the first time i've ever
driven a car before
i really wish you'd mention that yeah
that actually hurt my hand we can save
our world
but we have to fight together
[Music]
[Applause]
nope
i can't die
[Music]
you